[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Tom pellicero NFL Network
reporter part of the NFL Network's live
coverage of the scouting combine that'll
run through March 5th you go to these
press conferences and you know these
coaches and GMS are doing their best to
tap dance around but how do you sort of
decide I think I got something here or
that's something that the audience
should be aware of
well first of all uh Jason wallers who's
the Packers head of media relations
deserves a shout out for orchestrating
the Brian goodacood's experience
yesterday because what he they did was
they did like a 30-minute session with
the Packers beat reporters at like a at
the hotel so then in the time it took
good accounts to walk from the hotel to
the podium all the relevant quotes were
being tweeted there was nothing left
good accounts gets up there and goes
guys so I just you know you probably saw
I said haven't talked to Aaron not a lot
on that front so what else you got
Voodoo Goose was only on the podium for
seven minutes probably the shortest
Podium session in combine history
because at this point it's reflective of
the fact that there's only so much the
Packers can do Aaron Rodgers has control
over the situation because he's got 60
million dollars fully guaranteed because
he would need to rework his contract
whether to come back to Green Bay or to
be traded to help the Packers salary cap
and also he could simply refuse to show
up so the Packers have tried to be
patient here they're I'm sure are
lessons learned from 2008 when the
Packers pressed Brett Favre for a
decision he ends up retiring in early
March because at that point he didn't
think he could play by the end of April
he's already getting the itch and wants
to come back to the NFL and that
obviously led to drama over the entire
summer but make no mistake the clock is
ticking here the Packers need some
answers in terms of setting their free
agency plans we're 12 days away from the
free agent negotiating window opening up
and the first step in this process is
Aaron Rodgers saying number one
does he want to play because he hasn't
communicated that yet number two does he
want to play in Green Bay and even if
the answer is he wants to play in Green
Bay then go to Coons alluded to it there
are additional conversations that need
to be had just to make sure that
everybody is on the same page about the
direction of the roster the team the
organization moving forward this feels
like they've decided to divorce but
they're working on the language to tell
the children and then to tell the
parents I just there's just too much
there that it just feels like they're
down the road on this and I don't know
if Aaron wants to play again I don't
know if he wants to play elsewhere but
if I'm Green Bay I gotta move on
I you know I I just have to decide I
can't let him hold his hostage anymore
we have to build a team and if Jordan
love is that quarterback and you really
think that he can play then move forward
but and I don't need you to have though
if they you know they can't unilaterally
make that decision they have to make the
decisions with Aaron and I think that
one of the things that's been
misconstrued is this relationship is
predominantly positive and has been for
a couple of years since they hashed out
their differences back in 2021 and at
that time they adjusted Roger's contract
they deleted a year last year they
signed him to an extension that the
Packers quite frankly believed would buy
them at least one off season without the
drama and yet here we are talking about
Darkness Retreats and psychedelic
podcasts and trying to decide the future
here they have Jordan love they got a
glimpse of them in Philadelphia and more
importantly they have three years of
watching Jordan love every single day in
practice all that tape seen his
progression and good acoust has said it
publicly the next step is for Jordan to
play I don't see a scenario quite
frankly where Jordan love is on any
other roster than the Packers roster in
2023 they can exercise the fifth year
option that buys them at least into 2024
obviously you got franchise tags on top
of it you don't expect that you're going
to get to that road it's highly unusual
to have a first round quarterback or any
quarterback sit for four years but this
is also a unique deal and has been with
Aaron Rodgers and they again they
believed that they were going to have
Aaron for at least a couple years when
they did that contract the fact that
he's thinking about it now means he has
the power based on a contract that if
the Packers are going to get out of it
it's actually better for them for him to
retire this offseason the next offseason
but they simply don't know Tom pettocero
NFL Network reporter joining us from the
combine I also hate when I hear
reporters or analysts say I'm so tired
of the Aaron Rodgers drama I don't give
a damn about your feelings you still
have to cover it because it affects the
Packers it could affect the Jets it
could affect the Raiders affect Jordan
love we may not like it but it feels
like there's a real story here
how do you open this list
well for me yes it's you know been
several years of waking up every day and
not knowing what Aaron Rodgers might say
or do and how that might impact the
course of my day week month year pales
in comparison to the Packers wondering
you know hey this guy still gives us the
best chance to win in 2023 but does he
want to be here is he going to be bought
in if he is is he going to be traded is
he just gonna say I'm done and I've made
enough money and I've won four MVPs and
it's enough already
um you know from our perspective here I
think that you go back to last off
season and you think about how those
trades came together they all everything
beared on the next deal you had the
DeSean Watson situation where obviously
the serious allegations of sexual
misconduct and things that played a role
in this but he had a long-standing trade
request the Texans basically said here's
the price if you meet you can talk to
them four different teams did
everybody's bidding against each other
so it was basically free agency the
Browner told her out which causes Baker
Mayfield to request a trade Aid after he
sees that you know he's they're trying
to move on to that position then they
end up getting back in by giving a fully
guaranteed contract meanwhile the
Falcons also took a run at Deshawn
Watson which makes Matt Ryan go yeah I
think we're done here so then he becomes
available ends up with the Colts
meanwhile the Russell Wilson trade gets
done that causes Panic to set in for the
commanders they drastically upped their
offer for Carson Wentz so then they get
wenced if you think back on all those
trades I just mentioned there's not a
high success rate on any of these I mean
the Colts I don't anticipate we'll see
but I don't anticipate that Matt Ryan is
going to be a part of their plans this
year Carson Wentz has already been cut
the first year of Russell Wilson
obviously was not good in Denver with
DeSean Watson he hadn't played football
in two years it didn't look great but
it's you know 2023 will be a much more
uh Fair judge of it so you know in this
case you've got the Derek Carr situation
he's here in Indianapolis meeting with
Team Executives and owners as his free
agency carries forward here I know his
brother David said on NFL Network you
know he's going to take his time talk
with a lot of people well quite frankly
the best offer for Derek Carr may not
come until we know what's happening with
Aaron Rodgers Lamar Jackson John
Harbaugh and Eric DeCosta are going to
speak today there's no signs at this
point that a deal is close there and so
ultimately you're going to tag him we'll
see if it's the exclusive for the
non-exclusive tag there is a scenario
where they trade Lamar Jackson for a
windfall of draft picks the Daniel Jones
situation continues to play out Baker
Mayfield who eventually was traded last
year to the Panthers and then ends up
with the Rams who didn't have Matthew
Stafford a year after Stafford was the
big domino in the whole thing and kind
of set the stage for how all these other
teams are approaching this with saying
hey the guys available were moving
forward make your best offers and we'll
work it out you know all these things
are happening this is the league Den
where five years ago 10 years ago there
weren't trades nobody was trading these
things didn't happen yeah you'd have the
you know the offhand occurrence where
somebody at Carson Palmer became
available or you know Brett Favre who
ended up being traded to the Jets but it
wasn't a regular basis where last year
we had I want to say it was 10 trades
involving Pro Bowl players in a two-week
or 17 day spans now all of a sudden
you're once again talking about all
these quarterback dominoes leaning on
one another the moment the first one
Falls and we'll see what happens with
Derek Carr but quite possibly that will
be Aaron Rodgers declaring his
intentions once that happens I would
anticipate a lot of these other things
begin to move swiftly
what kind of Leverage does Derek Carr
have
share Carr's Leverage is that he's a
free agent these other guys were talking
about you need to trade for them so you
know if you're looking at Derek Carr
versus Jimmy Garoppolo who has won more
games have been to more playoffs and one
more playoff games than Derek Carr but
also has been hurt substantially more uh
than Derek Carr through his career so
you're evaluating him you're evaluating
Baker Mayfield you're potentially
evaluating Daniel Jones who will be
shocking if the Giants did not end up
franchise tagging him if they can't work
out a long-term deal here so you know
the question you have to ask yourself
your Derek Carr and his agent Tim
younger is
all right is our best offer going to
come right now do we have an offer we
feel comfortable taking because
potentially if Aaron Rodgers goes back
to Green Bay now all the seats are open
and we've got all the leverage Aaron
Rodgers gets himself traded and Lamar
gets himself traded now it's the best
seat there for Derek Carr and so there's
definitely a strategy to this entire
thing his Leverage is I'm available now
you can get me now and solve all your
problems and you don't have to give up a
pick to get me you know the Saints and
Raiders had agreed to the framework of a
trade when he took that visit but his
contract at that time was an issue the
Saints are still in it the Jets are
still in it the Panthers David Tepper
actually flew here to Indianapolis to be
with Derek Carr last night if all those
teams make offers and they're in line
with what their car thinks he should be
making he potentially could choose his
spot the question is is his best
leverage now or does it come after we
find out where some of these other
things land how important is Bryce
Young's height
not as important as Bryce Young's weight
in his frame talking to you know a
variety of different Scouts here over
the course of the week and we've seen
short quarterbacks go number one you
know Baker Mayfield was six foot Tyler
is I don't know what he's listed at so I
don't want a short sell him let's call
him 511. uh but they're shorter
quarterbacks but those guys are thickly
built you know Kyler was like 208 pounds
go back to Russell Wilson Russell Wilson
like Tyler is a baseball player baseball
players usually have they're thicker
they're densely built Bryce young was
listed at six foot 194 by Alabama
talking to Scouts you like went through
the school they say he's maybe 5-11 and
the quarterbacks don't measure until I
think I believe Saturday and they were
told he was playing at 186. there's not
a lot of precedent for 186 pound
quarterback now toss on top of it the
Bryce young was only hit like 15 times
or something last season he's playing
behind Five future NFL offensive linemen
so he's got the best protection possible
and he still suffered an AC joint injury
that impacted him uh for a good chunk of
the season so what you have to ask is
listen everything about Bryce Young
checks the boxes for teams except for
this in terms of great kid process as
well from a profile offense can really
throw it it's just Kenny hold up 17 Game
season now we'll see what he weighs in
at you know he may well be close to 200
pounds by the time he gets there but you
have to ask yourself that and I think
that that goes back to you know Lamar
Jackson there were some of the same
debate which was when he was coming out
through his lower body he had a thinner
type of a build well what's happened to
Lamar Jackson over the past couple of
Seasons he's had a bone bruise in his
ankle and he's had a knee injury that
cost him December in January in
consecutive Seasons you know there's a
lot of that and I know that it's it's in
Vogue to like rip on the the unnamed
Scouts and some of the opinions and that
like a lot of the stuff especially the
factual things build and things like
that end up coming true if you think
coming in that they're going to be
durability questions once a guy gets
into the NFL take Tua
tends to play out that way with Bryce
young we'll see you know he's clearly
just in terms of what he is as a
polished product right now he's the guy
who makes sense is the number one pick
there's just not Preston out there for
drafting 186 pound quarterback
especially not number one
that's the thing when you know I look at
the bear situation if there was a can't
miss or I thought can't miss and maybe
that's a Caleb Williams
then I would I would consider trading
Justin Fields if I knew that I could get
that guy reset the clock my rookie
quarterback contract and you know I'm
I'm able to build and now I got my
quarterback and how many times have we
said that about this you know Chicago
Bears hey you got a franchise
quarterback
but I just don't know about any of these
quarterbacks and as a result you know
probably I would keep Justin Fields
because I'm I'm just not sure that in
any of these quarterbacks are going to
walk in and remind us of Patrick Mahomes
the calculation you have to make here is
no team ever wants to be drafted number
one twice it happens you know Jaguars
did it you know it's possible to lose
that many games after draft at number
one but you don't want to ever be in
that position again so the way that I
would say it with what the Bears options
are here is they have scenarios for
everything depending do they get offers
for the pick depending if they fall in
love with the quarterback depending do
any of these defensive players whether
it's Will Anderson or Tyree Wilson or
Dale and Carter do any of them
you know jump out through the course
this process and they go we just we
can't afford to take the guy number one
I would also say that it's gonna be a
lot made of you know the idea that
they're gonna they're gonna trade that
pick listen every team in my 20 years
covering the league who had the number
one pick
and did not have an urgent quarterback
need wanted to trade it because you know
in the old days pre-2011 the contracts
were so astronomical you're giving Sam
Bradford 78 million or whatever
guaranteed coming out of college when he
hasn't played it down even now in the
slotted system you still would rather
move back because you know you move back
two spots three spots you're picking up
a future first round pick that's how
valuable it is according to every trade
chart but somebody's going to want to
give God has to want to give you that
pick so the real question is are any of
these guys somebody that other teams
below whether it's the Texans the two
the Colts for do any of them go we just
we have to get up to number one and take
this guy and to your point Dan I don't
know and we'll see the process always
kind of has the stuff shake out is there
gonna be somebody that everybody's
really comfortable with the questions on
Bryce young we just covered is just
going to be the the frame and the
durability you got CJ Stroud obviously
highly productive passer at Ohio State
but there have been a lot of Highly
productive pastors at Ohio State they
all come in with some level of the same
you know question to them I wouldn't
call it an issue because it can be
overcome but the the question is can
they read things the way that NFL
quarterbacks do because they're just
taught differently they're taught what
Ryan day does with them is just
different than what they're asked to do
in the NFL with Will Levis it's going to
be you know can he just kind of put it
all together does he have deploys last
year was a rough year at Kentucky but he
had nobody knew how hurt will Levis was
last year he had a really serious turf
toe injury that he kept re-aggravating
over and over when anybody who's ever
had serious turf toe knows I mean you
can barely walk much less go out there
and play quarterback Andy had a
non-throwing shoulder injury so that
really impacted his Mobility he was
having to shoot up the toe and the
shoulder on a weekly basis so you know
he didn't go to the Senior Bowl he is
going to throw here in Indianapolis so
you'll get a view on him and then you
get Anthony Richardson who is a traits
player all the way he's got the big arm
he's got the athletic ability height
weight speed all that but as one I
ranking executive who I trust told me
like quarterback isn't a traits position
you normally don't draft a guy who's a
one-year starter at quarterback who
hasn't really had the productivity
because you think you can just make him
into something the next level you don't
draft that guy in the first you might
draft him in the fourth but Anthony
Richardson people would be shocked
within the league and he doesn't go in
the first round he's gonna do everything
out here I mean he's gonna have a crazy
workout I'm sure with 40 and the
vertical and the broad jump and all that
stuff we're all gonna be going oh my
goodness this athlete then you got to
dig into okay can the quarterback
develop through the course of time
you're absolutely right there's holes in
all these guys I don't know that you're
sitting there feeling comfortable taking
any of them and number one that can
certainly evolve through the process
those guys generally get pushed up here
but you know the good news for the Bears
is you are sitting in a good spot where
you can get whoever you want whether you
can trade down it's easy to say yeah we
want to trade down we're going to trade
down somebody's got to be willing to
make it worth your while
always great to talk to you Tom have fun
there in Indianapolis
appreciate it man thanks uh Tom
pellicero great NFL reporter for the NFL
Network there's scouting combine
coverage is uh today through uh March
5th